finding dory floats onto the big screen
this summer and sees the return of
Pixar's plucky clownfish Nemo and our
favorite funny and forgetful blue tang
dory in this sequel to Finding Nemo
Dory's memory is triggered by a stingray
migration and she sets off on a quest to
find her family with the help of Marlon
and Nemo finding Dory promises to
explore a new chapter in Nemo's ocean
world so let's take a look at the new
and returning characters we can look
forward to meeting in the movie first up
is destiny a whale shark voiced by
Kaitlin Olson star of It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia destiny has difficulty
swimming straight due to poor eyesight
and realizing there's something familiar
about Dory she befriends the blue tang
when she visits the marine life
Institute whale sharks are the largest
fish in the sea and destiny herself is
not only very big-hearted but also
speaks whale which is very handy because
at the marine life Institute destiny is
friendly with Bailey a beluga whale
although they do like to poke further to
each other with Bailey calling destiny a
whale rather than a shark and destiny
making fun of Bailey's huge head Bailey
thinks his biological sonar skills don't
work properly
although the Institute's doctors don't
seem to think there's anything wrong
with him Bailey is voiced by Modern
Family star Ty Burrell speaking of
Modern Family Ed O'Neill ty Burrell's
co-star from the hit comedy series
voices Hank the octopus who is strictly
just a septa purse as he only got 7
tentacles hank is adept at camouflage
and escaping from tricky situations and
he's the first to greet dory at the
marine life Institute but he's only
willing to help her in return for a
ticket on a transport truck to a cosy
Cleveland facility where he'll be able
to enjoy a peaceful life of Solitude
in finding Dory Marlon and Nemo come
across a pair of snoozing sea lines
called fluke and rudder just outside the
marine life Institute they're voiced by
British actors Idris Elba and Dominic
West who worked together on the
critically acclaimed crime drama series
The Wire director Andrew Stanton said
that he wanted fluke and rudder to sound
like British gangster style talking sea
lions
when Nemo and Marlin encountered them
they're resting on a sought-after rock
and don't enjoy having their nap
disturbed although their bark is far
worse than their bite
Dory's mother Jenny is voiced by Annie
Hall star Diane Keaton
and her father Charlie is played by
American Pires Eugene Levy Dory's
parents don't suffer from quite in the
same memory loss as dory jenny is upbeat
and a little flighty but she loves Dory
dearly and wants to be a good role model
for her
Charlie loves to have fun although his
jokes probably aren't as good as he'd
like to think they are still the most
important thing to them both is teaching
their memory challenge daughter how to
survive loons replace the seagulls from
Finding Nemo and in finding Dory we meet
Becky an offbeat kooky loon who takes a
shine to Marlin and although Nemo is
skeptical about her she's probably
cleverer than she looks
the returning cast include Dory Nemo and
Marlin of course in finding Dory Nemo
has gone back to school after his big
adventure in Finding Nemo and is the
first to offer his help to Dory when she
decides to embark on her ocean search
for her family Nemo's father Marlin is
more hesitant about jumping in with
Dora's mission to head to the California
coast but he understands what it's like
to lose family and Dory of course helped
him to find Nemo the spotted eagle ray
teacher mr. ray will also be back and
this time Dory will be his teacher's
assistant during his student field trips
around the coral reef and seabed the
cool ocean turtles crush and his son
squirt returned again happy to lend a
flipper to a fish in need and the tank
gang who escaped from the dentist's
office at the end of Finding Nemo will
also be back for the sequel expected to
return of the moorish idol fish gil and
devorah blue and white damsel fish who
believed her reflection the fish tank
was her sister Flo and many fellow Pixar
fans are hoping we'll also see the
French shrimp Jack from the dentist's
office make a comeback too sadly the
original voice actor Joe ramped died
between the making of the two films but
his brother Jerome may step into the
role John Ratzenberger is rumored to
cameo again in finding dory as the voice
of the school of moon fish who appeared
in Finding Nemo and finally they'll also
be sea otters in finding dory lots of
cute adorable sea otters so guys who's
your favorite character from Finding
Nemo and how excited are you for the
sequel I'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below if you love Pixar in
animation you might also like my Pixar
Easter Egg videos twenty-five fun facts
about Zootopia and 27 awesome facts
about Kung Fu Panda 3 click on any of
these links here to check out those
videos
if you enjoyed this video do hit that
subscribe button for more videos like
this thanks for watching
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers